Oh Virginia North Carolina
I didn't I'm anything
I made her name
I did not know
[Music]
[Music]
No
sweet Jesus magically
[Music]
[Music]
purchase purchase number
see
my victory
[Music]
[Music]
and I don't you do these words for me
take them Matthew moon East Virginia
tell my dog and she is free
[Music]
that was a song called East Virginia I
learned from man named Clifton Hicks
lives down in Georgia next song I have
for you is called John Brown's dream
it's an old dance tune and you may
notice that the banjo that I'm holding
looks a little different than Anderson
you might be used to seeing or the one I
just played for example and this man Joe
is sort of an earlier model banjo has
kind of evolved like a human as and I
like to say that the sound that comes
out of this banjo is the sound that was
just a little closer to the source which
is Africa and some people forget that so
[Music]
[Music]
come on guys move again I'm gonna get
back at then I'm gonna get every little
girl
[Music]
[Applause]